[Music]
does this seem like there's more traffic
out in the roadways of late more
construction means more delays and two
particular parts of Charleston Boulevard
causing a lot of frustration among
drivers and business owners Madison
Kimbrough live near Charleston and
Rancho with what they're saying
yeah Brian the two areas that we're
talking about like you mentioned
Charleston and Rancho and then also
Charleston and Maryland
patient causing major delays now we
spoke to those who work in the area on
how this is affecting their business
I had no idea it was 18 months I'm
horrified our patients are late they're
canceling our older patients don't want
to drive not many people want to drive
through this
probably noticed there's a whole lot of
construction across the valley and it
seems to be everywhere you look the
traffic is is increasingly difficult for
our patients to navigate Barbara
Schwartz Thorne owns Speech Therapy
Associates and works along Charleston
and Rancho or an 18-month construction
project is underway upgrading the sewer
line and reconstructing roads it's very
difficult for our clients when they come
across this they can't make u-turns they
can't drive in three lanes they're just
driving in one lane Rebecca Bryant who
owns electrolysis Center of Las Vegas
admits it's put a real strain on her
clients I think I'll probably have to
put a sign up in the office and you know
just warn people just to leave extra
time here it it does affect us it
affects us quite a bit and if you drive
a couple miles east down Charleston to
Maryland you'll run into yet another
project and steadfast tattoo right in
the heart of it it's annoying for us to
get to work it's tough for our clients
to work because if they miss if they
miss this parking lot they got to go
down probably about two miles to turn
around and come back up and it's just it
I feel bad for them